gentlemen and ladies about three percent
of you welcome back to the channel
today's video is going to be pretty long
because it's on crdts which is a
complicated topic and frankly according
to my video analytics most of you tend
to only last about three minutes that
being said that's pretty good because I
typically tend to only last about one
minute so without further Ado let's get
into this video and get it done alright
so let's get started the iPad is out so
to remind everyone what was happening
last video basically we know that in
multi-leader replication we are prone to
write conflicts so I want to write
conflict inevitably happens what can we
do well we have three options the first
one is last right wins AKA lww which I'm
going to write right here
last rate wins is not really very
reliable because we can't really trust
time stamps in distributed systems
because they can get out of sync with
one another and jump around due to ntp
additionally a second option is we can
detect concurrent rights via something
like a version Vector which allows us to
see when two rights knew about one
another or did not and then we can go
ahead and store both rights in the
database known as storing siblings we
can eventually then have the user merge
them down the line
a third option is to actually have the
database merge them automatically so my
pen keeps not working here and that is
known as a crdt or of course a
conflict-free replicated data type so
what is actually the meaning of these
things well what is a crdt let's imagine
that we've got two liters over here on
our left and we're trying to build a
shopping list and we've got basically
two sets of items so on the left we've
got one guy who's written now uh ham and
eggs and on the right we've got a second
guy who's making conflicting rights
saying milk and cookies and what we want
is for these two sets to eventually
converge right we want both leaders to
agree on the value of the shopping cart
so ideally what we would want is
eventually both of those leaders are
going to agree that ham eggs milk and
cookies are what's actually in the set
that is the ideal scenario here so how
can we actually go about doing this well
that's going to come up in a bit but
let's first quickly in response to a
comment left by one of my viewers talk
about where crdts can actually be used
well some databases that we might see
them are ryak which is a multi-leader
leaderless distributed key value store
I'll talk about that more in a future
video and the second one is redis which
is a completely in-memory database often
used for caching in their Enterprise
version they use crdts for sets redis
again is something I will talk about in
a future video
so let's talk about two possible
implementations of crdts before I talk
about specific data structures that we
can Implement with them so let's recall
from last video the concept of a
distributed counter we're going to use
the distributed counter here to
demonstrate what an operational crdt is
so remember that we can demonstrate kind
of a distributed eventually consistent
counter by this list right here which is
basically a version Vector but the point
is every single element of the list
indicates how many increments we've seen
from each leader so there's two
delegates that we've seen two increments
from the first leader the one delegates
that we've seen one increment from the
second leader and then the zero says
that we've seen no increments from the
third leader now obviously each of these
leaders is going to keep their own
version Vector so that they can keep
track of their local state of how many
increments that they've seen and have
been set that way the counter is
actually just the sum of the elements in
the list so in the case of an
operational crdt what we're actually
doing is instead of sending this whole
list from one node to another in our
replication setup we're actually going
to send just an operation so in the case
of encounter there's only one operation
and that would be increment so for
example if this guy gets incremented and
this is said zeroth leader we might go
ahead and send Inc zero to the next
database and that's now going to change
its Vector to 3 comma 1 comma zero so
basically in this case again increment
just tells the database which index to
increment and the advantage of something
like an operational crdt is that you
don't actually have to send this full
Vector which grows linearly with respect
to the number of nodes but rather you
can just send one operation and this is
O of one in terms of space sent over the
network
it's a sent over Network because my
handwriting is terrible whenever I'm
rushed so what are the downsides of an
operational crdt because we said that as
opposed to sending the full Vector now
we get to send a lot less over the
network it's going to be a lot faster
well there is actually a pretty
significant downside which is that
whenever we have causal relationships
amongst our operations and operational
crdt could possibly let us down so let's
imagine that we have a set and we're
trying to implement that with a crdt
so in this case let's say on leader one
or database one I'll just write an L
here to indicate it's a leader and then
database two is also a leader on
database one we're going to first add
ham to our set then we're going to
remove hand from our set and then on
database 2 we're obviously going to be
propagating those operations so first it
receives the fact that we're adding ham
and then it's receiving the fact that
we're removing ham from our set
but what if I were to X this out right
here and in turn we never add him so
database 2 only gets that we're removing
him now it tries to remove ham from a
set that doesn't have ham in it and
we've got a problem it's going to throw
some sort of error and obviously that's
not acceptable the point is that these
two rights are causally related right
because you can only remove him if you
first added it so it's important
actually that if we have an operational
crdt we need a causally consistent
broadcasting system where messages do
not get dropped and they also don't get
duplicated because these operations are
not known as item potent item potent
meaning that here I'll write it here but
we'll see it later you can do the same
thing
many times over
and no difference
and I'm saying that these operations are
not item potent right if I send the
message add ham five times we're now
going to add five quantities worth of
ham so again this is not going to work
for us we need to make sure that in our
message delivery again we have no drops
and we have no duplicates so it's very
important for operational crdts
on the other hand we have our
state-based crdt and I was already
alluding to this before with sending the
whole kind of version vector or sending
the whole counter in a distributed
counter but that's what I'm
demonstrating here in this diagram so
let's say that this leader on the left
has a state of 5 comma four right it's
seen five increments to itself it's
seeing four increments from the Right
leader and it sends five four to the
second leader right because we're
sending the whole state of the crdt
instead of the operations
then in a state-based crdt as opposed to
just applying one operation to our local
crdt we call this merge function right
here and so on the Right leader we're
going to be merging our local crdt with
the incoming State base crdt and Via
this merge function we now have a new
result so after receiving 5 comma four
the right database merges and changes
itself to five comma six
so what do we actually have to know
about the merge function for something
like this to work well basically we know
that it needs to be commutative right
because if the basically we want the
same result whether the Right leader is
sending its results to the left leader
or the left descending its results to
the Right leader we also want it to be
associative again this just ensures that
no matter what order those State
messages are coming in we don't care and
we also again want it to be item potent
I just explained item potency before but
the point is if we receive the same
state multiple times over we're not
going to mess up our results right it
has no effect we just need to receive
that state once and we're good to go so
I have the the concrete mathematical
definitions down here you don't have to
focus too hard on those but if it helps
you understand what I mean when I say
these things that's good so the point of
this is if the merge function satisfies
all three of these things it means that
we don't actually have to care about
what order we receive these state-based
updates in unlike the Opera additional
updates which means we can just go ahead
and basically just fire out State base
updates all over the place and as long
as every single node gets them will be
eventually consistent so what does this
work really well with it works really
well with something called a gossip
protocol
so I haven't explained this yet in this
series but I did definitely explain it
in the past one basically the gist of
this is that it allows you to really
easily communicate with a bunch of nodes
in the cluster without any messaging
middleware how do we do this well
basically we pick one starting point so
let's imagine that this node had you
know its own counter base codt of one
comma two or something and it's now
going to pick say any two random nodes
in the cluster so it's got this guy here
and this guy here and now these two
nodes are considered infected so what
these two nodes are now going to do in
the next round of Gossip protocol is
also send its message to two more nodes
so as you can see now these guys are
infected and similarly
you know maybe it'll send it here it
doesn't matter if this guy receives the
message twice because remember it is
idem potent so receiving that message
twice is no big deal similarly you know
if we had another guy sending messages
because it has its own counter update to
send out it doesn't matter whether let's
call this message a and message B it
doesn't matter whether a gets there
before b or B gets there before a
because the merge function is
commutative so we're in great shape
either way we just need to make sure
that all those messages eventually get
passed around and then everything will
be eventually consistent so just to keep
demonstrating how this gossip protocol
is going to look this guy is infected
right here it's going to pick two random
nodes to pass messages to in the next
round all the newly infected nodes are
going to keep passing messages they're
going to keep passing messages
and eventually what's going to happen is
all of these crdt State updates are
going to get propagated around the
system such that we are eventually
consistent and everyone agrees on the
state of our crdt
that's great so again even though state
crdts are good they are
effectively pretty hard to implement
sometimes if the amount of data in them
is pretty big right because at the end
of the day gossip protocols have no
guarantees on necessarily when uh that
update is going to get there obviously
it probably will because just randomly
speaking probabilistically speaking the
message is going to get to a node but it
could take a while with all those random
iterations to actually get the message
to the right note additionally State
crdts can just be big and so they can
take a lot longer to pass over the
network
so now that we've gone over operational
versus state-based crdts let's take a
look at a few different types of data
structures that we can Implement via a
crdt and use well in a multi-leader
replication setup okay so the first one
that we're going to talk about is
actually going to be a distributed
counter so I'm trying to zoom here so I
get this one right but you know not too
bad just don't don't focus on the bottom
part of the screen I'm sorry all right
so the first one is going to be a
counter we already covered this it's got
one operation where you can basically
just call increase so if we wanted to
implement this via an operation based
crdt the operation would be increase
where the parameter would just be which
leader it's coming from
similarly uh it would hold all of those
increases in a single vector and then to
basically get the count on a node just
do some of the increase Vector right
because this would be basically six
we've seen oh my God I can't do math
holy it's five three plus two wow
who would have thought
um next we've also got a decreasable
counter this one has two operations you
can obviously increase that counter or
decrease that counter and the way we
would implement this on every single
node is similarly the last time we would
have a list of increments but we would
also have a list of decrements basically
where each decrement is saying how many
decrements have we seen coming from
every single leader node so in this case
the sum is very simple it's literally
just going to be summing up the
increments list 0 plus 3 plus 2 and
subtracting the sum of the decrements
list zero plus one plus zero so in that
case it would be four
so that's simple enough but we can also
do a little bit more complicated things
so let's go ahead and build out some
sets I've kind of been implying we could
do this anyway so let's do it so the
operations on a set would be adding and
removing and the way we can easily
represent us at on every single node is
we basically have all of the elements
that we've inserted that's called the
ads and all of the elements that we've
deleted which we will in turn call the
the remote
and so to actually get the
representation of the set on an
individual node you take all of the
elements in the Hat in the ads so in
that case that would be ham eggs and
cheese and then you would get rid of
cheese because it's in the remove set so
this works really nicely because now for
our merge function all we actually have
to do is take the union of two ad sets
and the union of two remove sets and by
doing so we can easily basically have a
right conflict-free representation of a
set now if you think about this there
actually is one issue with this
representation which is that once an
element goes in the removes list so Chi
is right here it can never be re-added
back to the set because I've said that
the set is you're basically if cheese is
ever present in the ads you're always
getting rid of it because it's in the
remove set
so how can we do this where we're
basically able to add an element back
well one way that would be pretty cool
is you basically just pick a random tag
with every single addition to the set
that you do so now in your ad set we've
got a ham with an ad identifier of one
two three eggs with an ad identifier of
762 and let's say some other leader
wanted to add ham again now the add
identifier might be two four one on the
other hand let's now say that at the
time the set only had these elements
right here that someone went ahead and
said I want to remove
ham one two three
and so now ham123 goes in the removes
list but at the same time if another
leader basically went ahead and said
okay well I'm adding ham 241.
we know that ham 241 hasn't actually
been canceled out yet so our resulting
set is going to be these two guys right
here so now we have eggs
and ham so by virtue of having these
unique tags we have to basically uh you
know know about the right already in
order to cancel it out and additionally
it means that we can rewrite things back
into a set which is great because it
limits us quite a bit less so moving on
to the last topic of the video which
isn't really a topic but it's more so a
teaser for a future video the last thing
we're going to talk about is sequence
crdts so this is basically making a list
in a right conflict freeway and that's
going to be really really tough because
the issue with the list is that it
depends on an ordering of some elements
and if you don't know about the elements
beforehand when you're making that right
it's kind of hard to just go ahead and
make an arbitrary ordering over them so
sequence crdts are very tough in
practice to actually implement but some
people have made them really well
there's some really cool open source
versions of these and they actually
power a lot of the technology behind
real-time collaborative text editors
like Google Docs or I don't know I think
um vs code has some text editor I'm sure
there are plenty of others you can think
of but the point is I am eventually
going to dedicate a video to these alone
because not only do they come up in
interviews but they're just a pretty
cool Topic in general that one may come
up in a while since it's a little bit
less relevant to what we're talking
about right now but either way hope you
guys are looking forward to it well guys
hope you enjoyed the video I will see
you in the next one and uh hope everyone
got through this if you only lasted
three minutes you're like all the rest
of the men in the world so don't worry
about it